guns shoot a kid at 13 years old own a
gun
I personally don't think so but I think
everyone's right by the way you know you
know with Republicans would I disagree
with them on here's what I disagree with
them on
I own guns
and I'm gonna buy a lot of guns
I was in the army
I like guns
I feel safer
first time I bought a gun I'm living in
my house with my wife and I we had a kid
range Rover's parked outside this is
2012. I go to sleep I wake up we're
living in ancient I'm thinking we're in
a good area somebody broke into my range
took everything took the system that day
I went and bought a gun I had to wait
four weeks for it but I went and bought
a gun you're not gonna mess with my
family it's that simple right but I
never bought a gumbo prior to that even
I was in the Army I think this concept
about me being able to go buy a gun same
day go home with a gun and and uh what
do you call it uh uh um rounds and all
this stuff without any kind of training
I think that's not smart I would much
rather require you before you want a gun
to do a one-week training
okay learn how to use it effectively
because I'd much rather have 10 million
people that know how to effectively use
guns than just letting anybody just go
by the gun and go home no problem that's
fine go take it home it's fine you just
sit about okay good no I think we need
to test what medication a person's
taking on someone many states do I think
we need to do a little bit of a
background check many states do but do
you know why the NRA doesn't want to
give the left this piece to negotiate
you know why
same exact reason why what's becoming
normal in school today because if you
say yes it is they're coming for this
this that's their fear that might might
my ambition would be to get everybody in
here to learn how to use a gun one week
training take this course just like you
get a driver's license guys that's my
for you to go buy a gun at a store and
come home but it's crazy it's a little
weird to me okay by the way Republicans
when I say this like what are you
talking about you don't have the right
to say something like that I made a
video Once the most hated video I ever
made
Texas I go to the store I buy an M16
with all the rounds
and I leave I record it took me 15
minutes to go in buying M16 get the
rounds go to my car
I don't think that's okay
I think you ought to go get a permit I
think you ought to go get training and I
want my state if I run a state I want my
state to have more trained people
knowing how to use guns than other
states also the the more destructive the
gun the more the training just like with
the driver's license you can't just
drive an 18-wheeler yeah that's
dangerous if you drive an 18-wheeler it
makes a lot of sense it's Common Sense
exactly because you need a more
sophisticated license so if you want to
have an M16 sure have an M16 if you want
a bazooka have a bazooka I'm not selling
that to them though
I understand also they're worried about
giving up a little bit of distance yeah
that's their worry yeah so I understand
there's a lot of money to be made and
lobbying for that there is no question
about that either I'm not going to sit
here and and by the way the more they
try to threaten to take guns away the
more gun buyers you know gun sellers
make money it's form of a military
industrial complex yeah it's another way
of making a lot of money
foreign